talibanes patrullando e incluso
escoltando a los militares de afganistán
imágenes que se repiten en dos ciudades
conduce al norte y farah al oeste es el
reflejo de una ofensiva que avanza con
un ritmo relámpago y acentuando el
control de los insurgentes en el país
una de sus más recientes capturas es la
capital de la provincia de baghlan
gracias a dios y con la ayuda de la
gente la ciudad de pul e khumri cayó la
cee la policía y otras áreas fueron
conquistadas el enemigo es despreciable
y nadie ha cooperado con ellos vinimos
aquí con la cooperación del pueblo y la
resistencia de muyahidin gracias a dios
toda la provincia cayó y los felicito a
ustedes musulmanes no presten atención a
la propaganda enemiga ya son nueve las
capitales de provincia que los talibanes
tienen bajo su control esto en medio de
una retirada de las tropas
estadounidenses que el presidente de byd
en confiesa no lamentar cinco de ellas
las provincias de nimbus farah vayan a
bajar y house hand están bajo el yugo
total de los rebeldes
se estima que su presencia se extiende
sobre el 65% del territorio afgano pero
según la inteligencia de eeuu tendría un
objetivo mayor fuentes del departamento
de estado de eeuu advierten que los
talibanes podrían aislar kabul la
capital en 30 días y tomarla en 90
desatando desde ya los peores temores en
la población
los enfrentamientos y la guerra traerán
destrucción como estudiante no tengo
esperanza sobre mi futuro no sé lo que
pasará a malata starbucks
la caída de kabul sería la derrota
completa para washington después de la
que fue su intervención más duradera en
la historia con cerca de 20 años y en el
horizonte europa empieza a mostrar temor
ante un nuevo éxodo humanitario grecia
ya advirtió que no está preparado para
una nueva crisis migratoria como la
vivida en 2015